[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
Bild es hat sich ein Leser bei uns
gemeldet Volker g der in Paraguay lebt
und mit Bernhard von Bredo befreundet
war der hat gesagt ich weiß nicht ob ihr
schon gehört habt aber hier mein Freund
Bernard ist zu Tode gekommen seine
Tochter auch das ist jetzt schon einige
Tage her und die Polizei hier tut nichts
könnt ihr bitte darüber
berichten herzlich Willkommen zu Tatort
Deutschland heute berichten wir über die
geigenmorde gerade habt ihr am Anfang
kurz die Stimme von Kai Feldhaus gehört
er ist einer unser erfahrensten Reporter
er ist für Bild schon um die halbe Welt
gereist und hat unter anderem vom
Erdbeben in Haiti oder auch von dem Fall
Maddy berichtet heute führt Kai uns
durch einen Fall der immer noch sehr
aktuell ist aber vielleicht auch
mittelfristig zu einem coldce wird ich
bin Mirko Kasimir und mein Name ist
Stefan Netzeband
hallo mehr als z Jahre ist es her dass
der damals 62 Jahre alte deutsche
Auswanderer Bernhard von Bredo und seine
14-jährige Tochter Lorena in ihrem Haus
in argua überfallen und erschossen
wurden das Mädchen war nach einem
Bauchschuss in der Badewanne verblutet
die Leiche ihres Vaters mit fterspuren
übersätt aber das interessierte vor Ort
erstmal niemanden deshalb rief ja Leser
Volker g aus Paraguay bei Bild in
Deutschland an und Reporter Kai Feldhaus
kümmerte sich um den Fall ich habe
daraufhin meinen lieben Kollegen Philip
lichterbeck der in Rio de Janeiro lebt
gebeten nach Paraguay zu fliegen und
sich mit volkg in Verbindung zu setzen
volkg hat mein Kollegen dann am
Flughafen abgeholt und direkt zum Tatort
Gefahren der auch Tage nach der Tat noch
genauso aussah wie in der Tatnacht
dieses Haus war komplett verwüstet
komplett auf links gedreht komplett
durchsucht es waren immer noch
Blutflecken am Boden der Tatort war
nicht gesichert das heißt die Tür war
nicht abgesperrt man konnte also da
reingehen und sich das alles in Ruhe
anschauen das ist bei einem Doppelmord
doch sehr selten die Polizei behauptete
damals im Herbst 2021 schnell die Mörder
hätten vier wertvolle Stradivari Geigen
erbeutet vier oder zwei ob das stimmt
also was gestohlen wurde und wer die
bredos ermordet hat all das ist bis
heute
ungeklärt aber um den Fall in all seiner
Rätselhaftigkeit zu erfassen sollten wir
zunächst die Opfer besser kennenlernen
und danach vier Menschen die vor Ort in
Paraguay eine wichtige Rolle gespielt
haben denn fest steht die geigenmorde
von argua lassen Kai Feldhaus bis heute
nicht los Bernard von Bredo war eine
faszinierende schillernde Figur er hat
mit mit 18 Jahren in einem Wald in
Bayern ein Mammut gefunden ein
mammutskelett hat daraus ein Museum
gemacht ist dann 2015 nach Paraguay
ausgewandert und hat dort davon gelebt
alte Geigen zu restaurieren also eine
ein sehr vielseitiger Charakter offenbar
auch ein bisschen schwieriger Charakter
wie uns viele Freunde berichtet haben
und als dieser Mann vor allen seine
Tochter in dieser Nacht zu Tode kam da
haben wir uns schon gefragt was genau
sollte denn das denn es war nicht ganz
ersichtlich was die Raubmörder von den
beiden wollten es kam da schnell das
Gerücht auf es seien in dieser Nacht
sehr wertvolle Geigen verschwunden es
hieß Bernard von Bredo habe Stradivaris
besessen und das hat uns natürlich
interessiert warum geht ein Deutschland
nach Paraguay warum hat der Stradivari
Geigen und warum sollen die geklaut
werden das mit den Stradivari Geigen war
natürlich ein spektakulärer Verdacht den
wir gleich aber noch ich sag mal
fachgerecht auseinand neehmen werden man
darf aber so oder so getrost annehmen
dass es sich bei diesem tödlichen
Überfall auf die von bredos um sowas wie
einen Raub handelte ein versuchten Raub
denn bei allen Spuren ging es um
Besitztümer und bei keiner dieser Spuren
um irgendwelche Beziehungsdramen oder um
Hass aber wie schon gesagt wurde
offenbar erstmal gar nicht ermittelt im
Herbst 2021 und das Haus blieb ein paar
Tage offen erst als Bild berichtete
schreckten auch die Behörden in Paraguay
auf und Beschuldigten ein paar Wochen
nach der Tat drei Menschen aus bredos
Umfeld Philip Lichtenberg der Kollege
also den Kai Feldhaus gebeten hatte sich
die Lage vor Ort anzuschauen der
berichtete im Winter
2122 dann bei
bildtv ja ich sag erstmal wo ich hier
bin ich stehe vor einem
Untersuchungsgericht die drei sind
gerade hierher gebracht worden werden
jetzt einzeln einem Haftrichter
vorgeführt sie sind hinter mir in fen
untergebracht und werden jetzt jeder
einzelne hochgebracht der Haftrichter
entscheidet dann ob die drei weiter in
der Untersuchungshaft bleiben oder ob
Sie eventuell sogar freigelassen werden
die Staatsanwaltschaft hilft den drei
ein Komplott vor das ist eine ziemliche
Räuberpistole muss man sagen dabei geht
es um Geigen Bernhard von Bredo das
Opfer soll zwei Geigen 2018 einem Freund
gegeben haben damit er auf sie aufpasst
während er selbst reißt in dieser Zeit
hat das Haus Feuer gefangen und die
Geigen sind offenbar verbrannt die
Staatsanwaltschaft sagt jetzt dass das
nicht stimmt sondern dass die drei diese
Geigen versteckt hätten und jetzt sie
verkaufen wollten und dazu brauchen sie
Echtheitszertifikat es soll sich im
Stradivaris handeln was meiner Erkenntis
nach Quatsch ist dazu brauchten sie eben
aber dann Echtheitszertifikat und um an
diese Zertifikate zu gelangen hätten sie
Bredo und seine Tochter eben gefoltert
und umgebracht die Polizei hat dann
Geigen gefunden bei einem dieser
deutschen und behauptet jetzt eben das
seinen die Geigen die damals nicht Brand
sein sondern von den drei versteckt
worden sein das ist also eine ziemliche
Räuberpistole es ist eine Theorie es
gibt dafür bisher keinerlei Beweise
Bernhard von Bredo bewahrte Bargeld
Wertgegenstände und Sammlerstücke in
einem versteckten Tresor in einem
zusätzlich gesicherten Schiffscontainer
auf seinem Grundstück auf die Ermittler
halten es für denkbar dass die Mörder
ihr Opfer folterten um so Zugang zum
Tresor zu bekommen aber das gelang ihnen
nicht die Polizei musste den Tresor nach
der Tat Aufschweißen von drei
Verdächtigen war bald nach der Tat die
Rede ihr habt es ja eben bei philiip
Lichtenberg gehört irgendwann waren
sogar vier Personen im Visier der
Polizei und die wollen wir uns jetzt mit
Kais Hilfe mal angucken wir beginnen mit
den Freunden von Bernhard von Bredo also
Steffen m und Volker g die regelmäßig
bei den bredos zu Besuch waren alle drei
Deutschen waren ganz gut befreundet
alles Auswanderer alle so um Mitte der
Zehner Jahre nach Paraguay gegangen und
haben da gemeinsam sich ihre Existenz
aufgebaut Stefan m ist der Mann der
Bernhard von Brel und seine Tochter
gefunden hat mit dem war nämlich der
Ermordete morgens verabredet ist da
nicht aufgetaucht Stefen EM hat sich
gewundert ist hingefahren hat den Tatort
unverschlossen aufgefunden und hat die
beiden Leichen gefunden das hat ihn in
den Augen der Polizei verdächtig gemacht
Volker g hat ab dem Auffinden von Vater
und Tochter ordentlich Wirbel
veranstaltet ihm war sehr daran gelegen
dass vernünftig ermittelt wird dass auch
ernsthaft versucht wird herauszufinden
was da passiert ist das ging ihm alles
nicht schnell genug daraufhin hat er die
internationale Presse eingeschaltet und
das scheint den Behörden auch nicht so
gut gefallen zu haben denn einige Tage
nach der Tat wurden sowohl volkg als
auch Steffen m festgenommen unter
Mordverdacht es gibt einen Artikel auf
bild.de auch Fotos von den beiden das
sind sagen wir mal das sind gemütliche
freundlich aussehende Herren mit
würdigen mitteldicken Bäuchen so wie
mittelalte Männer sie eben haben und um
mal in kriminalistische
Begrifflichkeiten zurückzukehren sie
sind trotz allen geklappers der
örtlichen Polizei keine besonders heißen
Verdächtigen Volk g und Steffen m haben
10 Monate in Untersuchungshaft gesessen
ohne dass man ihn konkrete Vorwürfe
machen konnte volkg hat immer wieder
betont dass er in der Tatnacht auf
seiner Ranch mehrere hundert Kilometer
entfernt war dafür gab es wohl Zeugen er
sagt auch man hätte das auf
verkehrsüberwachungskameras ganz
überprüfen können daran war aber wohl
niemandem gelegen die Polizei war
offenbar vor allen Dingen erpicht darauf
zunächst mal Verdächtige präsentieren zu
können weil die internationale Presse
sich plötzlich für diesen Doppelmord
interessierte nach 10 Monaten war es
dann soweit die beiden Deutschen wurden
aus der Haft entlassen ihnen wurde aber
unter auflag mitgeteilt dass sie
Paraguay nicht verlassen dürfen solange
die Anklage nicht eingestellt ist das
sollte in diesen Tagen passieren und
beide volkg wie auch Steffen m haben
angekündigt sobald die diese Anklage
eingestellt ist werden sie Paraguay
verlassen unsere Zwischenbilanz ist also
recht mager wir haben eine
Spurensicherung die wahrscheinlich eher
schlampig war das Motiv lässt zu
wünschen übrig und die zwei Verdächtigen
sind eigentlich keine interessanter ist
da vielleicht schon eV s ebenfalls aus
dem Freundeskreis der bredos und
ebenfalls eine interessante Person if S
ist eine hoch interessante Figur er ist
als Frau geboren hat als Junge
chellistin jugendmusiziert gewonnen hat
sich dann einer Geschlechtsumwandlung
unterzogen hat eine zweite Karriere als
Chirurg hingelegt hat in einem Hamburger
Krankenhaus gearbeitet und hat dann so
hat es mir gesagt in einem schriftlichen
Interview dass ich mit ihm im Gefängnis
geführt habe hätte er so ein
schleichenden Burnout erlebt und dann
beschlossen auszuwandern er hat sich
damals mit Bernhard von Bredo
angefreundet die beiden Männer haben
Grundstücke nebeneinander gekauft und
dort dann Häuser erricht
diese anfängliche Freundschaft ist dann
sehr schnell in die Brüche gegangen IFS
wirft dem später ermordeten vor er hätte
ein sehr wertvolles Cello unterschlagen
eines das IFS von seinem Vater geschenkt
bekommen hat das hätte Bernhard von redo
aufbewahren wollen und ihm nie
zurückgegeben tatsächlich ist eV S bis
heute in Haft und Vorwürfe gab es
zwischen ihm und Bernhard von Bredo auch
in die andere Richtung umgekehrt hat
Bernhard von Bredo zu Lebzeiten IFS was
vorgeworfen und zwar brannte unter sehr
dubiosen Umständen 2018 das Haus von IFS
ab in diesem Haus befanden sich mehrere
Gegenstände von Bernard von Bredo die so
sagt IFS bei diesem Brand vernichtet
worden sind von Bredo hat IFS
vorgeworfen er hätte diese Gegenstände
unterschlagen um damit sein Cello
freiupressen IFS behauptet die
Gegenstände die er aufbewahrt hat sei
nie wertvoll gewesen das einzig
wertvolle das wirklich verschwunden sei
sei eben dieses chellow das er von von
seinem Vater geschenkt bekommen hat dass
Bernhard von Bredo ihm weggenommen hätte
noch schildernder ist Person Nummer 4 in
diesem Jahr wie nennen wir das Quartett
der Verdächtigen Nummer vier ist ein
Anwalt namens Jimmy Paes in diesem an
schrägen Figuren nicht unbedingt armenf
ist Jimmy Paes der vielleicht seltsamste
von allen Beteiligten er hat Bernhard
von Bredo in verschiedenen
Streitigkeiten vertreten ist offenbar
bekannt dafür gewesen dass er vor allen
Dingen sehr krawallig seinen Beruf
ausübt und nach dem Tod von Bernhard von
Bredo kreuzte Jimmy pas plötzlich auf
und hatte ein Testament des Verstorbenen
indem er zum Alleinerben erklärt wurde
das ist nicht nur in Ermittlungsbehörden
seltsam vorgekommen man hat das dann
relativ schnell durchschaut und
herausgefunden dass eben dieses
Testament gefälscht ist was nicht ganz
klar ist hat er das selbst gefälscht
also hat er die Unterschrift gefälscht
oder ist möglicherweise eine
Unterschrift von Bernard von
in der Tatnacht ihm unter Folter
abgerungen worden das ist ein Element
das noch untersucht wird das ist
mutmaßlich das Element aus dem am Ende
auch eine Anklage gezimmert werden kann
gegen eben diesen Anwalt wie genau das
ausgeht ist aber nicht ganz klar denn
die Mühlen in Paraguay malen was das
juristische angeht sehr sehr langsam
beide Verdächtige sitzen jetzt seit fast
zweieinhalb Jahren in Haft und gegen
beide ist immer noch keine Anklage
erhoben also verschiedene bekannte des
Opfers sind unterschiedlich schwer
verdächtig das erinnert ein bisschen an
sowas wie Mord im Orientexpress nur dass
hier alles noch schwerer zu begreifen
ist gab es denn wohl wenigstens eine
oder sogar zwei oder vier Stradivari
Geigen in diesem Fall nein es ist davon
auszugehen dass Bernard von Bredo
niemals eine Stradivari besessen hat es
ist davon auszugehen dass die Polizei
das verwechselt hat er hatte zwar eine
ganze Reihe von Geigen ganze Menge davon
waren auch noch da als man den Tatort
dann irgendwann untersucht hat es waren
wohl auch einige verschwunden aber IFS
behauptet aus dem Knast heraus Bernard
von Bredo habe niemals wertvolle
Instrumente besessen es gibt also sehr
wenig Konkretes an diesem faszinierenden
Fall zumal es sehr unwahrscheinlich ist
dass jemand mit so wertvollen Objekten
wie diesen Violinen wirklich etwas
anfangen könnte man muss daz auch eines
Wissen stielt man eine Stradivari es
gibt noch ungefähr 600 auf der Welt
dann ist sie im Grunde unverkäuflich
denn es ist sehr genau nachgehalten wo
welches Instrument ist das heißt auf dem
Schwarzmarkt Wirt man das Ding
eigentlich gar nicht los ganz abgesehen
davon dass die potenziellen Raubmörder
ja erstmal wissen müssten was ist denn
jetzt die Stradivari und was ist
vielleicht dieige Geige und welche
nehmen wir mit und welche lassen wir
hier Steffen m und Volker g warten in
Paraguay immer noch darauf dass gegen
die beiden anderen Verdächtigen endlich
Anklage erhoben wird damit sie das Land
endlich verlassen K Volker g formuliert
es so wir leben hier eigentlich im
Paradies die Sonne scheint die kohiibes
Fliegen herum aber nach der Zeit im
Knast kann ich mich an diesen
Kleinigkeiten nicht mehr
erfreuen auch Steffen ist fertig mit
Paraguay er sagt für mich ist es
undenkbar an Paraguay zu bleiben wenn
ich die Leichtigkeit des Lebens wieder
genießen will dann muss ich hier weg ich
lebe mit der latenten Angst dass die
mich wieder für nichts einsperren
wird der Fall also noch aufgeklärt wird
man Schuldige verurteilen können fragen
wir ein letztes Mal wildreporter Kai
Feldhaus ich kann mir vorstellen dass es
zu ein Prozess kommen wird sollten die
beiden Verdächtigen allerdings dabei
bleiben dass sie mit der Tat nichts zu
tun haben dann werden Sie möglicherweise
trotzdem verurteilt ich bin mir aber
relativ sicher dass wir nicht erfahren
werden was in dieser Nacht wirklich
passiert
[Musik]
ist und das war's für heute unser Fall
haben Stefan Netzeband und Kai Feldhaus
zusammengefasst Postproduktion durch
schwarz audio berlin wir freuen uns wenn
ihr auch beim nächsten Fall wieder dabei
seid euer Stefan und euer
Mirko dir hat diese Folge von tartout
Deutschland gefallen du bekommst von
True Crime einfach nicht genug dann hör
jetzt in unsere weiteren Folgen rein
hier warten mehr als 200 spannende Fälle
auf dich wie das Verschwinden von
Rebecca Rusch Prozess gegen OJ Simpson
oder die Entführung von ursela Hermann
wir hören uns bei Tat Deutschland